In the US, 77% of workers who have a Facebook account...
...say they check their updates at work.
In the United Kingdom,...
...a similar survey of workers shows 57% regularly log on to social networks,...
...resulting in 40 minutes of lost worker productivity per day.
Philip Wicks is a consultant at London-based technology research firm, Morse PLC.
It isn't just something that you can just do for half an hour during a lunch break...
...but all through the day and because of that, it has a huge impact...
...because people just aren't necessarily concentrating on what they should be during the day.
Wicks estimates social networking during office hours...
...costs businesses in the UK about two and a quarter billion dollars a year.
Workplace consultants say the losses will grow as social and blogging sites attract even more users.
Some workers say networking sites are helpful in exchanging ideas, boosting morale,...
...or finding the right candidate for the job.
Certainly, LinkedIn on the professional level...
...is a very useful tool in connecting with other professionals.
But others argue online socializing is best left outside the office.
If you want to spend time on the weekends on it or in the evenings, it's fine.
But, I think most people are probably too busy,...
...should be too busy, to do it at work anyways.
Studies show the amount of time people spend on social networking and blogging sites...
...has tripled since last year.
Employers are fighting back.
A recent survey shows 54% of US companies...
...have already banned social networking and blogging while on the job.
Mil Arcega, VOA News.